[Music]
you are faced with overwhelming power
your highest priority it should be
simply to survive
there may be a very small opportunity to
escape
don't let your guard down
samus aaron the most powerful bounty
hunter in the galaxy embarks on a new
mission to the uncharted planet zdr
her objectives confirm whether the
deadly x parasite still exists and
figure out why the emmy research robots
in search of it have mysteriously gone
dark
early readings reveal that planet zdr is
divided into multiple environments
each with its own elements
and organisms
remnants of the mighty chozo
civilization are also scattered
throughout including evidence that the
chozo may have once called the planet
their home
visit
metroid.nintendo.com to read metroid
dread report volume 8 for a detailed
account of the terrain and life forms
you may encounter in the metroid dread
game
be sure to view the other metroid dread
reports there as well
you'll want to prepare yourself for the
dangers that lie ahead
metroid dread launches on nintendo
switch october 8th pre-orders are
available now on nintendo eshop